ce débat intitulé écologie et
capitalisme tend l'encontre profit
immédiat
nous avons plusieurs invités donc à ma
gauche jean marc jancovici qui à
ingénieur consultant sur les questions
climatiques
bien connu du grand public car écrite
par le livre de vulgarisation sur ces
questions d'énergie il ya toute une
génération et que dire de scientifiques
qui ont été libres les assez libre et
j'en fais partie
c'est le premier livre sur cette
question là que j'ai lu et qui est
jean-marc que continuer à être très vue
d'une bonne partie de la communauté
scientifique on est très content qu'ils
aient accepté cette invitation
aurélie trouvé qui va très rapidement
arrivé un peu en retard mais en quelques
minutes et sera ici qui est porte parole
d'attac et puis alain pagano responsable
à l'écologie du pcf et qui est aussi
professeur enseignant nicolas gillet de
conférences en écologie à l'université
d'angers et enfin pierre alain millet
qui est élu adjoint au maire à
vénissieux en charge
de l'écologie alors voulu ce débat
le titre on est un peu l'explicité on
est dans le monde contre profit medien
bon la contrainte de la taille du titre
mais parlant on entendrait le fait qu'
il ya une grosse inertie par rapport aux
écosystèmes qui sont qu' on doit agir
très vite pour pour empêcher la crise
globale écologique et en août en un
système économique qui n'intègre pas ces
tambours et qui a une vision qui est un
m
c'est du court terme crise globale
climatique une crise des ressources
énergétiques mais pas que et puis une
crise de la biodiversité on parle d'une
d'extinction de masse de 5e extinction
de masse que commettrait la planète
actuellement qui est l'indicateur fête
finale de cette crise globale en cause
kylie a évidemment la démographie c'est
vrai le planète à 1 milliard d'habitants
une planète à 7 milliards et bien qu'ils
aient milliards on a une marge de
manoeuvre beaucoup plus faible mais il
ya une dimension énorme
évidemment cet accroissement de
population il ya des centaines de
millions de personnes qui rend selon le
développer
c'est une bonne nouvelle parce que il ya
une sortie de la pauvreté donc on on
peut pas être content c'est complètement
légitime et une dimension énorme de
gaspillage de ce système qui est
inefficace à répondre aux besoins qui
est qui on y arrive
donc on a commandé une dimension de
gaspillage de ce système économique qui
qui a du mal à répondre à cette crise
cette crise écologique
alors la tentation nous
je voudrais diffic dégonfler un débat
là-dessus c'est que la tentation c'est
qu'on a souvent une lecture de renvoyer
à l'individu à la responsabilité
individuelle à la consommation
individuelle pour changer les choses se
raconter mais c'est un détail
l'essentiel quand même c'est c'est quand
même de de réorienter toute cette
économie là au service des gens de
l'écosystème de l'environnement dans
lesquelles vivent les gens donc on doit
engager une réorientation complète de
cette économie
il existe des plans l'onu propose des
scénarios énergétiques le giec en
propose qui implique de gros
investissements et la question de
justement ce débat c'est comment
contraindre ce système pas dans une
réorientation des dans une
transformation
profond là plusieurs héritiers ya les
beauty de la réglementation métiers du
service public
l'outil de la contrainte par la loi et
cela dépend de vision dépend aussi de
notre rapport au capitalisme parti
communiste mais pour dépassement du
capitalisme mais aussi d'autres visions
des choses d'autres visions d'autres
propositions
et voilà le l'objet du débat vers
jean-marc qui a beaucoup réfléchi à ces
questions de économique parce que ça
avant tout quand même une question
économique et commande pouvoir régler ce
problème du réchauffement climatique de
la biodiversité etc dans une planète à
sept milliards d'habitants et bientôt à
10 milliards
comment cette proposition que les jeux
télé sa parole jean marc
et j'ai trente secondes pour trouver la
solution du rsa il ya pas de solution
miracle
en fait il ya un certain nombre de
mesures qui sont des conditions
préalables indispensables dans la
première c'est d'avoir une idée claire
du problème à traiter et aujourd'hui on
en est malheureusement encore très très
loin
il ya une énorme différence entre
beaucoup entendre parler d'un problème
est bien comprendre le problème et si je
suis tout de suite un tout petit peu
taquin les malheureusement le niveau
d'information on trouve dans les grands
médias n'est pas du tout suffisant pour
se faire une idée claire du problème à
traiter
c'est clair que dans les déterminants du
problème il ya le nombre de milliards il
ya un autre individu qu'il ya sur terre
un la terre fait de mettre direct
aujourd'hui que faisait il ya deux
siècles sahara a changé donc un peu plus
de place et il faut partager de manière
un peu plus forte en ce qui concerne le
climat
il ya énormément d'idées imprécise qui
circulent sur la façon dont se présente
le problème par exemple je ne sais pas
qui dans la salle c'est qu'une fois
qu'on a mis du co2 dans l'air il faut
attendre un siècle en siècle porte la
moitié scénario il faut attendre milan
pour que 80 % s'en aille il faut
attendre dix mille ans pour que 90 %
s'en aille
donc ça veut dire qu'on a on est face à
un paul totalement irréversible on peut
pas se dire le jour où on a un peu trop
chaud à la j'appuie sur le groupe 27 et
on va remettre les choses en état c'est
quelque chose qu'ils n'ont pas de sens
je ne sais pas qui dans la salle c'est
que l'approvisionnement pétrolier
européen il contraint à la baisse depuis
maintenant plus de dix ans et que c'est
la raison pour laquelle la croissance
économique ne vient pas je ne sais pas
qui
dans la salle a conscience du fait de
tout de suite dire une horreur que
malheureusement même le mode de vie des
smicards français ne peut pas être
étendue à huit milliards d'individus en
très longtemps donc on est face à des
choses comme ça qui sont des choses
dures difficiles
pas désagréable à entendre et pour
l'essentiel on a une idée très mauvaise
des contours du problème avec les cathos
pores qu'on n'a pas là je veux en venir
tant qu'on n'a pas une idée claire du
problème à traiter c'est très très
difficile d'avoir un débarras bulle sur
les solutions sap et ça joue les liens
on sait pas exactement en brune
problèmes discutés où est la solution au
problème est un truc qui tourne un peu
dans le vide
ça sera le prochain
petite réaction oui je pense qu'il faut
être à la fois dans les questions de
société les questions système on a un
système qui est gérée par l'appât du
gain
confiée à court terme et qui va puiser
dans les ressources naturelles de
manière à considérer deuxième chose on
est dans un système qu'il a favorisé la
recherche vous pouvez à tout prix par
exemple c'est pas moi qui fais cette
espèce de la scène pour aller chercher
par exemple dans les pays où salariaux
des marchandises des productions que ces
terrains en générant des déplacements
inconsidérés pour répondre à la demande
de l'offre de la demande plutôt et la
saaq ou écologique est très important et
sur lequel je crois qu'il faut que alors
ce que vous dites est tout à fait exact
il y aura l'ouverture dans les questions
climatiques par exemple puisque c'est
une des questions qui nous occupe et en
même temps je crois que c'est de notre
devoir citoyen je veux pas me prendre un
parti politique de donner des
perspectives de solutions et les
perspectives de solution immédiate
qu'ils soient nature à mobiliser les
citoyens parce que quand on entend si on
veut rien dans dix ans d'aston villa
je suis un peu schématique mais il ya
des gens qui portent ce discours là
c'est pas très mobilisateur pour
l'action moi je crois qu'on a besoin
d'apporter des solutions très concrètes
et par exemple je vais me situer toutes
échelles qui mériterait d'être plus en
mai à l'échelle de la france
le transport s'apaisent
30% des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre est ce que oui ou non
politiquement blanche dit politiquement
je parle pas politiquement manière
partisane
est-ce que l'on politiquement on a envie
de porter quelques solutions immédiates
qui nous permettent de réduire
l'empreinte carbone du transport en
favorisant par exemple les transports en
commun gratuits en disant que la tva va
la mettre à 0% pour favoriser l'usagé du
trac c'était axes d'accès
donc moi je crois je m'arrête là qu'on
reprendra la parole des accusateurs plus
tard je crois que c'est juste
d'expliquer scientifiquement les choses
en même temps on a besoin de dire il ya
des solutions qui sont impossibles souk
el abida gien la dernière chose que je
voulais dire je crois que ya besoin de
faire grandir l'idée que l'écologie ça
va nécessiter des choix politiques
structure pour moi l'écologie ni droite
ni gauche c'est un peu une blague parce
que on va devoir s'affronter un système
économique qui fait les mauvais choix
les ou valoir qu'on avance ensemble
collectivement un système qui propose
des bons choix pour la planète
[Applaudissements]
on accueille aurélie qui est qui qui
vient de
et donc quelles solutions pour
transformer système quels sont les
obstacles le rapport au capitalisme le
rapport aussi aux échanges globaux
l'exploitation etc
bonjour à toutes et tous désolé pour le
retard j'avais quelques contraintes
familière qui m'ont fait partir un peu
tard de chez moi d'autant plus désolé
que j'ai pas tout entendu de voix là
parce que tu as bien j'aurais aimé alors
je ne sais pas combien de temps qui me
lie à l'heure où libre voilà les noms je
pense la première idée qui me sens très
importante cette question de l'écologie
c'est d'abord que sa demande de mon
point de vue une remise en cause
profonde des logiques capitalistes
actuel est dû est vraiment du
capitalisme financier néolibérale mais
plus globalement des logiques
capitalistes de profits de court terme
parce qu en fait investir dans le long
terme pour des questions écologiques sa
demande aussi de sortir de cette logique
de profit de capitaux qui domine
aujourd'hui le capitalisme le
capitalisme tout court
et du coup l'idée que et c'est ce que
nous attaquons défense et que le
capitalisme vert c'est une impasse
totale points c'est un green washing est
pire que ça c'est une façon pour le ces
nouvelles façons pour le capitalisme de
s'adapter à de nouvelles attentes
sociétales ou comment ici à date bas
avec ce qu'on appelle greenwashing c'est
à dire le verdissement de toutes ces
politiques mais qui ne change rien de
façon très très marginale à sa logique
profonde
or cette logique qu'au fond elle est
totalement contradictoire avec la
résolution de la crise écologique et
j'ai donné quelques exemples mais eux
c'est que les bras armé
aujourd'hui du capitalisme néolibéral
c'est les accords de libre échange on en
parle beaucoup en ce moment parce que ce
cas l'accord entre l'union européenne et
le canada qui est sur la table du
gouvernement du parlement et du sénat
faut espérer le sénat va peut-être leur
poussée s'animera sur la table du
parlement dans quelques semaines et ça
risque d'être acceptée parce que le
gouvernement soutient ça faut savoir ces
accords de libre échange c'est pareil
pour l'accord qui est actuellement en
qui vient d'être finalisé avec le
mercosur
là je dirais peut-être la première des
conséquences de ces accords de libre
échange
c'est là c'est l'approfondissement du
désastre écologique c'est pour le canada
en fait la première raison de cet accord
c'est qu'on faciliteront l'union
européenne les imports de pétrole issu
des sables bitumineux qui est sans doute
un des pires une découpe de piles
sources d'énergies fossiles qui puisse
exister au lieu de 1er la mobilité
l'efficacité énergétique les énergies
non renouvelables en fait vers le choix
qu'on fait sur le mercosur c'est quoi
c'est en fait donné à nos
multinationales la possibilité de
pouvoir avoir accès à l'extraction
minière notamment dans la forêt
amazonienne c'est aussi du pouvoir on
importera davantage de viande bovine et
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire la
déforestation de l'amazonie du cerrado
et c'est donc de deux milieux forestiers
qui sont les poumons de la planète et
c'est ça qui est derrière ces accords de
libre échange qui sont profondément qui
sont au coeur du système capitaliste
actuel de la même façon il faudrait
aujourd'hui tu es bien investir
massivement des énergies fossiles
là aussi ça veut dire contraindre très
très fortement les mutations et mettre à
bas le régime honni puisque c'est elle
qui ont les premiers intérêts dans
l'investissement dans les énergies
fossiles de ce point de vue là le
gouvernement vous savez soutient cette
extraction d'énergies fossiles à travers
des subventions publiques qui sont quand
même assez massive de la même façon à
résoudre la crise écologique c'est aussi
stoppé tous les congés nuisibles les
projets d'autoroutes derrière celle 1,6
et les multinationales
ces soupes et les grands projets
nuisibles et imposer que sont par
exemple europa city comme derrière ces
mots chance et voilà c'est juste à côté
donc c'est aussi se confronter à voir un
rapport de forces radicales très fort
avec les multinationales raison pour
laquelle de mon point de vue l'écologie
ne peut pas être une écologie de droite
où elle ne sera qu'une écologie une
écologie du goût du greenwashing et une
écoute cette écologie ne peut être qu
anticapitaliste en fait elle ne peut que
remettre en cause profondément la
logique capitaliste et de ce point de
vue là j'arrive maintenant sur les
solutions concrètes que dont tu permets
et moi je vais reprendre là je pense
aussi qu'il ya une chose très importante
aujourd'hui à gauche c'est vraiment de
réussir l'articulation entre l'écologie
et le social
d'abord parce que les premiers
responsables et voir si la question
écologique elle est profondément social
c'est-à-dire les premiers responsables
de la crise écologique
ce sont les pays riches ce sont aussi
les plus dans les pays riches c'est à
dire ceux qui par la mode de
consommation entraîne le reste de la
population de romans de consommation
totalement insoutenables émis
aujourd'hui je sais que ça fait grincer
des dents parfois dans certains cercles
y compris de gauche il n'y a pas d'autre
solution que la sobriété c'est à dire la
baisse de la consommation matérielle
énergétique à l'échelle globale
évidemment
aux classes moyennes et petites pierres
avant tout réduire leur consommation
mais au niveau global
dans nos pays riches on est obligé de
descendre cette consommation matérielle
énergétique de manière drastique
on nous oblige il si on veut ne pas
dépasser les 2 degrés par exemple
laisser 80% des ressources fossiles d'un
sol et ça ça demande une transformation
profonde de nos manières de consommer de
produire et d'échangés ça veut dire
aussitôt faire en articulation entre l
écologie sociale ex as pas contre les
classes moyennes et précaires contre les
travailleurs contre les chômeurs etc et
je prends l'exemple de la taxe sur les
carburants qui est l'exemple typique de
l'écologie qui se fait contrer classes
moyennes et précaires cette taxe sur les
carburants qui était conquis fin la
hausse proposée par le gouvernement
pourquoi il ya eu ces réactions d'abord
parce que c'est une taxe inefficace
pourquoi pas parce que c'est là parce
qu'on va augmenter le prix du carburant
qu'il y aura des solutions pour faire
autre chose en matière de transport ce
cas rien qui a été proposé par ailleurs
et deuxièmement c'est injuste parce que
ce sont les classes moyennes les
précaires qui payons plus dans leurs
revenus aux carburants
donc qu'est ce qu'il faudrait faire
manière très concrète ça va rejoindre ce
que tu fais ce que tu disais c'est un
fax et déjà les premiers pollueurs qui
sont les grands sites industriels faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui le marché car
enfin c'est à dire la taxe carbone
l'état ce pardon les les taxes sur les
industriels et les quotas carbone en
sept sont quasiment gratuit cédant sites
industriels ne fonctionne pas
c'est la preuve aussi que le capitalisme
vert et les logiques et les solutions
marché financier ne fonctionne pas
aujourd'hui il faut une taxe absolument
efficace sur ces grands sites
industriels et que ce soient les
premiers à payer
deuxièmement évidemment stopper les
accords de libre échange
troisièmement tu l'as dit et
transparentes un vaste programme je
pense plus que ça de planification
écologique portée à l'échelle nationale
portée à l'échelle des collectivités
locales ça veut dire perdre et un vaste
programme
de transport en commun gratuit de
rénovation thermique des logements y
compris dans les classes moyennes et
précaires de relocalisation des
activités et services publics et
commerces de proximité ce qui est
totalement contradictoire avec des
projets comme l'europe à city qui seront
à côté est notre logique française
totalement ahurissante des grands
centres commerciaux qui viennent les
centres villes qui viennent des villages
de leurs heures de leur commerce de
proximité
ça veut dire dans tout un tas de
solutions qui peuvent être à la fois
écologique et sociale et non la part
font là pendant une plateforme
d'associations et syndicats qui exigent
qui est la création d'un million
d'emplois pour le climat parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a un million à cause
d'un million d'emplois dans la
transition écologique dans cette
rénovation des logements pour ses
transports en commun et cetera pour
l'agriculture biologique et tant
d'autres un million d'emplois ça
demanderait 5 milliard d'euros au bas
mot si c'était des emplois publics tel
qu'un peu moins les emplois aidés et
externe
en tout cas avec quelques dizaines de
milliards d'euros on peut y arriver
et là évidemment la droite même là la
soi-disant cloche qui n'est pas dans
cette perspective la réponse mais on
retrouve on retrouve ce fric et bien
d'autres où on trouve dans une lutte
efficace contre l'évasion fiscale
64 81 milliards d'euros on le trouve
dans une taxe sur les transactions
financières qui à l'échelle française
vaincu permettrait de récupérer
plusieurs dizaines de milliards d'euros
on retrouve par la fin de subventions
publiques aux énergies fossiles et la
fin des exonérations surtout sur le
kérosène le fioul etc
donc il ya aujourd'hui des propositions
à la fois sociales écologiques qui
permettent de créer des emplois et de ne
pas en déduire qu'ils permettent
également de résoudre la crise
écologique et je finirai l'absolu en
france on est en retard
vous savez qu aux états unis il ya toute
une réflexion
on condamne grignotines radical porté
par les démocrates européens et des
personnes et des politiques comme
occasion portait ce qui porte cette
transformation radicale en france on est
encore très très faible sur cette
réflexion là mais oui new deal radical
je pense qu'aujourd'hui c'est ce qui
nous permettra à la fois d'affronter la
question des inégalités sociales et la
question de la transition écologique de
manière sérieuse crédible et régionales
à la grèce ont messi aurait dit ils se
trouvèrent que le giec est depuis les y
construire des scénarios énergétiques
qui tienne compte de tous âges très
fière de transports économie circulaire
le la rénovation énergétique des
bâtiments
la transformation de leur culture or
ceci dit si ce scénario la table quand
même sur une augmentation à ponctionner
un gentil parce que la démographie et se
fait ailleurs qu'en europe et aux états
unis
on est à 13 milliards de tonnes de
équivalent-pétrole faudra produire 20
milliards en 2050 pour neuf milliards
d'habitants fixés
c'est alors peut-être que caire alain
qui a réfléchi à ces questions
énergétiques j'ai aussi tu es dans une
association sauvons le climat
de quoi peut-être récent rapport à ça
cueillez merci je voudrais partir d'une
expérience d'élus communistes sur
l'écologie pour montrer que de vie / eco
ev liste de faire de l'écologie
autrement différemment de ce qu'on
entend en général
à partir de deux petits exemples de
traits contraire parce que pour moi pour
un élu local
l'écologie c'est d'abord une bataille
médiatique le premier exemple c'est les
composteurs de quartier à vénissieux
ville dont vous avez peut-être entendu
parler pour des problèmes de sécurité
les composteurs de quartier sont ouverts
24/24 libre d'accès il ya un agent
municipal qui passe régulièrement pour
rayer que ça se passe pas trop mal mais
ça se passe bien mais honnêtement ces
composteurs de quartier ne sont rien par
rapport au volume des déchets collectés
sur la ville mais ils sont un incroyable
outil de pédagogie et pour voir en vrai
objectif c'est ce qu'on peut appeler de
l'éducation populaire pour maîtriser des
sujets qui sont complexes et qui
malheureusement sont surdéterminé par le
discours médiatique dominant un
composteur par exemple peut-être
certains ça mais ça émet des gaz à effet
de serre émet du co2
si tout le monde se marre un composteur
partout est ce que quelqu'un a calculé
le volume d'émission de sa représente
non personne ne s'y intéresse
est-ce qu'il est pertinent de collecter
les déchets compostables pour les
emmener dans un digesteur qui
fabriquerait du gaz
peut-être je n'ai pas d'avis à priori
mais où c'est con mais ce débat citoyen
réellement perspective
c'est ce qu'on essaie de faire un
délicieux mets deuxième exemple c'est à
côté des messieurs et des terres
agricoles qu'on appelle les grandes
terres et depuis 20 ans ont fait tout un
travail de fourmi avec des classes
scolaires qui viennent planter des haies
avec d'aider des associations qui nous
aident et en travaillant avec les
adducteurs pour garder est diversifiée
on travaille avec un agriculteur
d'ailleurs s'en sont pas s'en passer à
tf1 ça fait dix ans qu'on a discuté les
agriculteurs pour réduire l'usagé des
pesticides et les éliminer dans les
champs à proximité des maisons mais ça
aucun média
on a parlé et sur cet espace on est
passé en quinze ans de trois espèces
d'oiseaux nicheurs à 45
voilà un résultat qui nous manque
quelque chose dès qu'il y à volonté
politique et qu'on agit la nature
reprend ses aises et donc les discours
du catastrophisme sont absolument
dangereux parce qu'il faut l'effet
inverse
ils produisent la peur augure de
produire de l'intelligence et tout ça ça
me conduit à dire on a vraiment besoin
d'un vrai débat politique
je prends un troisième et dernier
exemple la question de l'électricité est
désolé nerfs électrique
vous avez vous pensé tout ce que le
photo volée et versements pertinent vert
est positif mais vous savez peut-être
quand même que aujourd'hui pour
l'essentiel le photovoltaïque chez les
particuliers est développé sur des
propriétaires de toits qui ont été payés
par des primes fiscales et un tarif
d'achat garanti qui lui est payée par
tout le monde sur sa facture y compris
les abonnés aux tarifs sociaux
est ce que c'est un problème oui moi je
pense que c'est un problème quand on met
des milliards d'argent dans une
technologique est fondamentalement sinon
c'est sur l'inégalité sociale
ça me paraît être une bonne solution
d'ailleurs si on prend l'allemagne je
conclurai dessus l'allemagne depuis 15
ans a investi des sommes faramineuses
sur les nerfs électrique
pour quel résultat elle n'a pas réduit
sa consommation ce aussi pour
l'électricité et donc elle n'a paralyse
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre et
est donc pour moi c'est une impasse
voilà le débat citoyen politique il faut
avoir que les communistes reporté
et merci clair avant elle a parlé tout à
l'heure
simple concentrer sur les questions du
climat et on a parlé du quinze du
pétrole du canada
le charbon on a encore ce en plusieurs
siècles avec la consommation actuelle
est de l'avis des spécialistes il
faudrait absolument ne pas brûler le
charbon qui a signé comment contraindre
le système parfois ça c'est à dire parce
que derrière et a dit souhaiter le
profit énorme malentendu
l'analyse relayer des bagadoù qui montre
bien célèbre cette contradiction là
alors je me tourne vers jean-marc j'ai
bien lu tant livre sur la décarbonation
de l'économique de tournée du chef de
projet on va quand même essayer donc et
dans ton livre tu as une approche qui
est différent de les analystes
conseillent les partis communistes du
front de gauche
un certain nombre d'analystes pour le
financement pour contraindre par la
réglementation de réorienter tout ça et
notamment sur une des priorités c'est de
comment dire de très vite arrêté le chat
l'utilisation du charbon à l'échelle
européenne
est ce que tu peux détailler entité
proposition fait dans shift project
bonds dire ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure je pensais qu'on allait par le
trident chacun sait que très rarement
j'ai une très bonne nouvelle pour les
gens dans la salle
la production de charbon je vais essayer
de parler plus fort qu'en face tant sûr
que j'y arrive a été divisée par quatre
la production européenne de charbon ont
été divisées par quatre depuis 1981 donc
le charbon il déjà en baisse et il était
en baisse bien avant qu'on ait des
problèmes de climat tout simplement
parce que ça fait deux siècles contact
dans les mines de charbon en europe et
donc il y aura de moins en moins donc
c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
parce qu'on n'a pas les idées claires
sur le problème à traiter on part dans
le décor sur la façon de le traiter
donc les centrales à charbon en europe
il y en a plus c'est la raison pour
laquelle les financiers disent qu'ils
vont désinvestir du charbon vous avez
peut-être entendu un certain nombre
d'entre eux dire ça qu'il se trouve que
les deux zones dans le monde où le
charbon est en croissance
c'est les l'inde et la chine pour
l'essentiel les financiers occidentaux
du repas accepte toute façon donc c'est
super simple gros de dire qu'ils vont
désinvestir du charbon et a pas de
projet en dehors de toute façon forcée
du quick win alors qu'il suffit de dire
si un journaliste il y bravo bravo et
les gens sont formidables
c'est juste que toute façon il ya plus
d'argent à faire matin il faut savoir
qu'aujourd'hui par exemple l'allemagne
le concert des beats de charbon à ciel
ouvert qu'on appelle de la ddte en
matière d'écologie je pense que si vous
préférez peut pas être pire dans
l'énergie et l'allemagne n'a plus de
charbon de la houille ou de l'anthracite
ces trucs là elle l'important totalité
aujourd'hui donc la consommation de
charbon en europe est orienté à la
baisse depuis des décennies déjà
alors il faut aller encore plus vite
nous ce qu'on dit c'est que si l'europe
c'est notamment un truc qu'elle doit
faire c'est faire en sorte que toutes
les centrales à charbon de via rail et
disparaissent de en fait sur toutes les
centrales à charbon dit se baser la
planète dans les 30 ans qui viennent
s'est en outre dit on devrait voir des
mama faso en avant a essayé difficile
donc que pour ceux d'entre vous qui
rentrent cet objectif des 2 degrés de
limitation du réchauffement climatique
une des contreparties c'est qu'il ya
plus une centrale à charbon sur terre en
les 30 ans qui viennent on a pour
rebondir sur ce que disait mon voisin de
gauche c'est évident qu'on va pas y
arriver juste et des panneaux solaires
et des éoliennes et s'est par ailleurs
évident qu'on va pas y arriver sans
sobriété massive mais là je me très
bonne nouvelle pour aurélie trouvé
s'asseoir à 6,6 la macroéconomie fait
que la sobriété c6 donc la bonne
question c'est si on est pour la
sobriété
comment est-ce qu'on organise la mise au
régime général et là j'ai une deuxième
mauvaise nouvelle pour vous c'est très
bientôt riche mais comme disait coluche
si on n'a pas assez pour que ça suffise
donc moi je ne suis pas fait pour des
problèmes avec ça même si je fais partie
des gens concernés mais ça suffira pas
il suffira donc le débarrasser du
charbon pour 1 pour 1 point à redire
c'est quelque chose qui en europe n'est
pas très difficile maintenant ça suppose
une chose qui n'a rien à voir avec le
capitalisme c'est de passer sur le corps
aux allemands parce que les allemands
veulent pas en parler du nucléaire et
sans nucléaire on ne supprimera pas le
charbon en europe dans les 30 ans qui
viennent c'est pas la patte du compte et
ça n'en fera pas
[Applaudissements]
donc cette armée je voulais un deuxième
sujet qu'il faut comprendre puisque
maintenant j'ai droit à l'entente parole
sur la mobilité
en gros ce qu'il faut faire et je vais
faire un tout petit truc qui va pâtir
applaudir dans la salle
si vous vous rappelez du régime
soviétique il n'est pas qui était pas
tellement plus tard pour l'environnement
que logique capitaliste donc l'idée que
c'est juste une affaire de régime
politique que je dis non c'est plus
compliqué que ça c'est lié au fait que
les hommes sont des animaux accumulatif
on en a jamais assez est le problème il
est là avant d'être d'un régime
politique dont on a un problème de
psychothérapie collective à avoir qui va
au delà du régime politique dans lequel
on vit en fait le régime politique on
est plutôt la conséquence pour revenir à
la mobilité
en gros le système qu'il faut organiser
c'est des voitures plus petites avant
dépassé à l'électricité et le truc qu'il
faut faire savoir faire des deux chevaux
ont décru de 500 kg qui concerne 2
litres aux cent c'est technologiquement
ça pose aucun problème et en restant au
pétrole en utiliser la quantité de
pétrole qu'on consomme parfois en 30 ans
c'est facile ça s'accompagner d'
obligations réglementaires du retour de
la vignette quelques supprimés par
habilis de gauche pourra comme prévu ce
qui était un impôt parfaitement écolo et
s'accompagne évidemment du développement
des transports en commun mais là aussi
il ya une règle tout faux connexes et
que faire du rer
à moins de 100 habitants ha c'est
compliqué faire de glisse à moins de
grains invitant ha c'est compliqué donc
ça veut dire qu'il faut que les gens
vivent vous ayez des concentrations un
peu denses comme les villages dans
toutefois les villages d'autrefois où
tout se faisait à qui et à cheval les
gens ils n'habitaient pas 100 mètres les
uns des autres
il était passé donc si on doit reprendre
la maîtrise de l'urbanisme
il ya un vrai sujet qui est ce qu'on
laisse que permis de construire au vert
voilà où est ce qu'on dit non non on va
pas les laisser faire ce qu'ils veulent
c'est aussi un sujet de débat car rien à
voir avec le capitalisme et le le préfet
et les odeurs de l'état a donc après on
renvoie à la question qui est est ce que
l'état qui a peut-être intelligent ou
pas je suis parfaitement d'accord
en attendant si le maire fait ce qu'il
veut si l'état est intelligent ça suffit
pas du coup donc donc un sujet sur
l'urbanisme aussi à traiter en même
temps l'urbanisme saignant à l'époque où
tout ce qu'on avait comme transport
c'était des charrettes à bras et des
chevaux paris dépasse pas le million
d'habitants c'est à dire que le disque
agricole qui permettait de nous et paris
à moins d'une ou deux journées de
transport des denrées agricoles ne
permettait pas d'avoir une ville qui
dépassent le million d'habitants nourrir
10 millions franciliens dans un monde
sans pétrole c'est impossible c'est
impossible c'est demain matin je publie
les camions dans ce pays pareil meurent
de faim
la ville de france produit 5 % de la
nourriture qu'elle consomme donc tout ce
système là il est très très lent à
détricoter
alors est ce que la part du capitalisme
dans cette affaire-là est majeur
la part du capitalisme financier
sûrement en ce sens qu elle raccourcit
les horizons pas donc moi je vais faire
deux autres propositions ici je pense
qu'ils sont supprimés les comptes
trimestriels et la captation en continu
des entreprises parce que ça je suis sûr
que ça raccourci les horizons de temps
est ce que il faut totalement supprimée
alors je ne suis pas le premier du tout
à avoir inventé un mot russe à l'aide il
est déjà ça une entreprise ne change pas
de valeur toutes les minutes et qu'elle
en l'appâtant une fois par semaine c'est
bien suffisant
travailler dans ce monde là je sais très
bien dans la quasi totalité des
entreprises qu'on appelle une stratégie
de long terme ça se baladent n'importe
où entre simon et trois ans et donc
c'est pas du tout suffisant aux échelles
de temps dont on est en train de parler
dans le monde politique on n'est pas une
stratégie de long terme dans le monde
politique quand ça déplace deux ans mais
bien servi
quelle que soit la couleur politique
donc il ya un vrai problème de pâques
tombe dans cette affaire qui n'est pas
juste non plus un problème de capteur
politique alors je suis parfaitement
d'accord que tout ce qui va dans le sens
de libéralisation mondialisation
raccourci les papes temps donc ça c'est
pas une très bonne idée et par ailleurs
supprime la possibilité de préserver les
activités qui sont pertinentes pour
l'environnement puisque vous les mettez
en concurrence avec des activités qui
nous préserve quoi l'environnement et de
la nature est gratuite ou en fait que la
nature gratuites dans l'économie qu'on
manipule
toute personne qui se donne une charge
supplémentaire c'est-à-dire la
préservation de l'environnement est par
construction dans ce monde là plutôt
défavorisés grâce à quelqu'un qui ne
fait pas cet effort ça c'est
parfaitement su que même moi qui écris
salaires c'est parfaitement réagi il
n'empêche qu'à d'étape tu qui sont pas
en confiance avec l'étranger d'accord
l'isolation des logements en france
c'est pas en concurrence avec ce qui se
passe à taïwan donc il ya des tas de
trucs sur les quais on n'a pas besoin
d'attendre la suppression des accords de
libre échange pour commencer à s'exciter
mais je suis parfaitement d'accord que
les accords de libre échange sans
contrepartie environnemental c'est un
truc qui ne va pas exister aujourd'hui
mais j'insiste pour finir sur un point
ça fera un bond et puis donc la bonne
question pour moi aujourd'hui c'est
comment j'organise un monde de
contraction économique parce que c'est
bien ça quand on parle dans un contexte
dans lequel on est quand même contents
de se lever le matin et de regarder
l'avenir
voilà ça c'est un problème autrement
plus ardue qu'un certain nombre d'autres
trucs dont on a l'habitude de discuter
[Applaudissements]
merci jean marc les dimensions de
provocation qui est qu'on retrouve aussi
dans tes livres métier très plaisant
parce que ça me bouscule ses rangs c'est
pas mal de choses mais ça m'oblige à
répondre aussi à travailler donc et
pierre des convergences
il faut que les souliers sur sur
certains restaient qu'a posée par là
même la question du financement ou tu
disais tondre les riches ne suffira pas
se dire les impôts les impôts ces sujets
là bas et donc il faut trouver des
sources de financement pérenne parce que
là il est question de plusieurs dizaines
de milliards d'euros par an non pas pour
produire pour produire mais pour faire
un saut jusqu'à ce que la rénovation
énergétique des bâtiments
ces 15 milliards par an il faut il faut
les trouver et donc là on a une
orientation du système financier aux
défauts penser et puis il ya peut-être
aussi la question de l'agriculture ont
peut-être que tu pourras réagir aurait
dit puisque tu es à bordeaux et qui
avait aucune crise sur ces questions
match presque réagir sur les propos de
jean-marc son financement
et j'étais moins de choses à répondre un
des sources de financement oui j'ai dit
tout à l'air d'avoir trouvé plusieurs
dizaines de milliards d'euros
faire c'est une question que de soi
nationaux et passe et pas forcément en
faisant exploser la dette
par ailleurs il ya une banque publique
d'investissement vous savez sauf qu'elle
a des ailes à des moyens très restreint
pour être tout à fait envisagée que les
populaires qui va vers les banques
privées haye avant tout vers la banque
publique d'investissement qui
permettrait ensuite à l'état d'avoir de
pouvoir emprunter à cette banque
publique d'investissement à des taux
zéro qui puisse lui permettre de mener
ces grands ces grands projets cette
planification écologique dont notamment
la rénovation thermique des logements
qui doit être devant fendu gratuite ou
quasi gratuite pour pour les classes
moyennes les précaires et ça c'est une
vraie mesure à la fois écologique et
sociale j'ai maintenant parler de la
question de me suis fait plusieurs
choses arrivent d'abord la
relocalisation des activités augmenter
les prix je suis désolé absolument pas
d'accord ça a été montré à pas depuis 10
ans nous dans lequel vous prenez avant
localisation les activités habitants
s'étaient montrés remontrer une point de
vue académique scientifique c'est à dire
que vous pouvez très bien en court
circuitant les grandes industries
agroalimentaires en court circuitant les
d'abord l'ailé et la grande distribution
dont la marge est plus en plus
importante
donc en faisant en sorte pour quatre ans
leurs marges en régulant leurs marges
sont les courts-circuits tant par les
circuits courts pouvez tout à fait ne
pas faire augmenter les prix et la
preuve c'est qu'aujourd'hui dans un
tabac il ya un tas d'études qui montrent
qu'en mangeant locales par des amap des
biocoop etc et en transformant aussi
notre mode de consommation moins
transformés etc
on peut tout à fait manger y compris
moins cher et les cantines qui jouissent
aujourd'hui sur le local et le j
emin la plupart s'en sort pour moi de
coûts de revient
tout en tête passe par sodexo par
exemple ça demandera aux municipalités
en partie donc ça demande aussi de
s'attaquer au capitalisme excusez moi
parce que s'attaquer à sodexo par
exemple c'est s'attaque à la géorgie
capita les hégémonies la multinationale
et c'est avoir des choix très fort au
niveau local qui sont des choix au fond
de gauche et qui vont contre ces voix-là
et ses conseils de me tomber à vous
parce que je sais que c'est là votre
logique également sur la question
sociale si on bat sa consommation
énergétique et matériels sauce récessif
et pas non pas forcément
en fait les militaires ni nécessite plus
de croissance
parce que l'on en fait ça dépend du type
de croissance et la croissance c'est
quoi cette produit intérieur brut seller
valeur ajoutée brute de chaque secteur
ce qui est énorme a reconnu l'économiste
nessuno que c'est le cas oui la valeur
les valeur ajoutée brute c'est les
valeurs monétaires et par exemple si
vous prenez les agriculture bio et
javier cultures économes autonome et
c'est qu'ils sont plus favorables sur le
plan écologique
elle craint aussi pour beaucoup plus les
valeurs ajoutées donc en fait elle crée
une version plutôt un ancien de la
croissance ils ont enquêté croître
certains c'est une activité très
nuisibles liés par exemple à
l'extraction d'énergie fossiles etc
il faudra faire croître par contre
d'autres activités très utiles et
d'autres peut pas dire aujourd'hui que
parce qu'on veut la transition comme si
ça sera forcément récessif dont je suis
pas d'accord du tout et ça et je pense
que du point de vue économique ça tient
pas sur la question du nucléaire
alors là aussi on a des accords s'cusez
moi là il ya des dizaines d'ingénieurs
scientifique d'accorder comme ce qui ont
travaillé sur le scénario négawatt
c'est quoi ces sobriété efficacité
énergie
renouvelable c'est pas que les énergies
renouvelables c'est aussi l'efficacité à
travers les logements la rénovation des
logements etc
les transports en commun et c'est aussi
la sobriété et montre tout est très bien
j'espère vaste pouvoir se passer de
l'énergie nucléaire est restreint a
fortement aussi les sources d'énergie
les plus polluantes
dans ce cas là en faisant jouer ses
ouvriers d'efficacité énergies
renouvelables
je me rappelle quand même que le
nucléaire c'est d'abord une source
d'énergie
telli mais à la fois pour les
travailleurs qui travaillent mais aussi
terrible du point de vue des risques
environnementaux et c'est aussi
extrêmement coûteux et ça explique en
partie la dette aujourd'hui de ds mais
passons donc comprendre sachez que voilà
le nucléaire c'est à la fois courte et
luzi et que oui aujourd'hui avec une
grosse volonté politique pourquoi
[Musique]
la news sur salaire est une erreur qui
capitalise pas si sa totale aux accueils
logique capitaliste cette affaire-là
parce que sa demande ne sont par exemple
non seulement de ralentir les accords de
bien d'avoir des accords de libre
échange et des améliorations
environnementales
bien sûr comment il faut stopper les
accords de libre échange est où ce sont
des accords de libre échange et katy
nous on est paralysé les échanges ce qui
aujourd'hui est d'abord puis des armes
des multinationales pour affronter
profite à partir du moment où cet axe
donc dans cette logique la
libéralisation des échanges
on va faire le désastre et
l'approfondissement de la crise
écologique n'y a pas d'amélioration à
attendre des accords de libre échange
il faut les stopper êtes-vous de
régulation internationale du commerce
qui soit complètement autres et qui soit
fondée à la fois sur la solidarité et
sur un certain nombre de régulation du
commerce et des équilibres monétaires
dans le mot qui n'ont rien à part
aujourd'hui à l'est ce que sont les
accords de libre échange est ce qu'est
l'organisation mondiale du commerce et à
logique
[Applaudissements]
merci oui on a des convergences mais
aussi des débats y compris à gauche
je rajouterais juste parce que c'est
mais nos questions énergétiques c'est
que le giec
lui-même reconnaît que sans une part de
nucléaire
il est impossible de créer la question à
la fois climatique et la demande
énergétique mondiale
et là c'est le giec je pense pas qu'on
puisse dire que le giec a raison quand
ils nous alertent sur le réchauffement
climatique la partie du gel qui nous dit
qu'il faut du nucléaire dans le monde
eh bien c'est la mauvaise partie par
écouter donc cnrc pas eh ben c'est pas
ubs qui me disent c'est vraiment les
instances internationales les meilleurs
scientifiques du monde qui le disaient
oh je vais revenir quand même sur la
question
[Musique]
la question du financement
peut-être les propositions du parti
communiste sur
le financement les sources de
financement la réorientation du crédit
est ce que peut-être pas eu lieu
réagi vos sièges qui s'est déjà dit
ouais mais avant je propose qu'on abatte
la bande à messi plus fort moi aussi bon
déjà peut-être une première réaction sur
un ce que disait jean-paul ici sur nous
sommes des êtres accumulatif et ses
potes question système alors certes
moi je crois qu'il ya une part
d'individus l éducation populaire a
travaillé pour éviter qu'on soit un
cumulatif est quand même le capitalisme
et inventer un truc formidable qu'on
appelle la publicité qui nous travaille
dans le sens de la cumulatif et je crois
que une des réponses qu'on pourrait
avoir d'ailleurs qu'on soit
anticapitaliste pour le soit pas c'est à
dire la publicité ça fait partie des
choses qu'on devrait restreindre ou
interdire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même si c'est pas trop je vais prendre
une deuxième chose que je voulais dire
tout à l'heure que a parlé du c'est un
dur ce soit
je crois qu'il faut je crois qu'il faut
dire de manière assez simple
compréhensible par les gens le c'est un
ennemi ressources et la promotion des
circuits longs et nous ce qu'on veut
c'est des circuits courts et je pense
que ça cette question extrêmement
importante et sur kei aux parlementaires
qui ont déjà refusé en première lecture
le ceta serons très vigilants
parlementaire comme lille pour se poser
à ces traités de libre échange et
maintenant si on appelle un chat à
chasser complètement des traités
capitaliste c'est dans une logique
totalement capitaliste et j'ai pas tout
dévoiler de ce que dira fabien roussel
dans un petit moment sur la grande scène
de l'humanité dans son discours je pense
qui parlera beaucoup d'écologie et
notamment il dira nous
ahmed banco ce milliard d'euros sur la
table pour c'est ce qui est proposé
d'ailleurs par les nombreuses
associations
oui j'ai scientifique pour résoudre la
crise économique et la crise climatique
or the deer 100 milliards d'euros par an
c'est beaucoup d'argent
certes mais en même temps ça a été dit
il ya 80 milliards d'euros par an qu'on
devrait récupérer sur les ai payés tous
les gens qui font de l'évasion fiscale
et l'évasion fiscale ces points vous
autour de ce débat c'est surtout des
gens dont un patrimoine immensément
riche et qui vont essayer de le planquer
dans les paradis fiscaux
deuxième proposition qu'on fait c'est
une proposition qu'on a défendu au
moment de l'élection européenne et pour
lequel confirme à cette proposition
c'est que la bce la banque centrale
européenne qui aujourd'hui prête de
l'argent sur les marchés financiers que
cet argent soit réorientée à 0% pour le
développement notamment des services
publics sans même sortir des traités
européens renégocier etc
c'est une décision politique qui prend
une prise aujourd'hui si des choses que
je voulais dirigera cammas que ce que je
vais trop long
le saviez vous aujourd'hui maquereau a
dépensé 14 millions d'euros et tous les
joueurs de 2019
l'état français dépense 14 millions
d'euros par jour
37 milliards d'euros sur cinq ans pour
la rénovation pour la rénovation des
armements atomiques français des armes
nucléaires françaises emma voilà le 21
septembre c'est la journée
internationale pour la paix mais votre
concept ans et la marche au climat
on va construire ensemble et pacifiste
et les écologistes pourraient cannes et
des gestes pour le climat je pense qu'il
devrait demander à maquereau gèle ses 37
milliards et affectent tout ça hein vous
écologique et sociale et moi quand on
sait les principales qui est pas pour la
gratuité des transports en commun par
exemple il y aurait largement de quoi
financer tout ça voilà une proposition
qui me paraît extrêmement concrètes
appropriée par tout le monde et je pense
qu'on a besoin de ce genre de choses
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci alain effectivement c'est une
dimension du gaspillage qu'on oublie
souvent les débats mais gaspillages liés
à l'armement dga ce père y est alarmant
qui tiennent à l'armement le
conventionnel il ya dix ou de
financement aussi
ce côté là alors peut-être que je vais
tenir parole
quelques questions du couple à 500
interactif
hier
[Musique]
oui j'aurais fait injuste de 3 la
première de méthode sur dans ces
discussions il ya d'égoïsme capitalisme
socialisme tel ulysse par rapport aux
questions environnementales et
écologiques
ce qui serait bien c'est l'émeute à la
st c'est à dire de ne pas démarrer par
voilà moi je suis pour le capitalisme
moi j'ai pour le socialiste on verra
bien à la fin de la discussion
parce que après tout si le bien qui me
dit je suis pour le capitalisme et comme
je suis aussi pour l'environnement la
vision long terme etc
je veux bien impliquer tout le pognon de
supprimer la publicité arrêter des
transports inutiles au niveau mondial et
puis faire ensemble que dans les
entreprises quand on hésite ce qu'on va
produire on prenne d'abord en
considération les intérieurs l'intérêt
général écologique et c'est aussi à la
fin les deux quand même continuer après
ça le capitalisme
je suis pas super g les quoi donc
commençons d'abord par parler
concrètement 2 comme on vit quand
quelques bons produits avec quoi on se
développe
et puis chacun sera la conclusion qui
voudra la deuxième chose c'est que je
sais bien qu'il ya des préjugés qui est
des départs ancien terrain mais c'est
quand même mieux c'est dans ce genre de
débat on ne sombre pas dans des sacs
roxy nation et on sera franchement a
fait ce cadeau pour y trouver
non le nucléaire français n'est pas
coûteux c'est pas possible de dire une
ânerie pareille
sinon comment elle pourrait avoir le c
3po cela je veux bien qu'on discute que
c'est dangereux qu'il faut toujours
veiller kaveri tout ce que vous voudrez
mais non ce n'est pas coûteux et si edf
a demandé ça ap ces quinze dernières
années
c'est pas à cause du nucléaire parce
qu'ils ont construit la demande 0,10 à
coeur
d'ailleurs ça n'a rien à voir sur
d'autres choses
donc non je veux bien qu'on discute des
risques de radioactivité n'est pas qu'on
me dise que le nucléaire français
je parle pas du nucléaire en général
vous pouvez avoir dîné clair très
coûteux mais les médias français il
l'est pas voilà c'est tout c'est les
chiffres
ensuite c'est pareil pour les
discussions sur quelques produits etc
il faut réaliser relocaliser et fo
notamment deux cas lisez la simplication
manufacturière en europe en général et
en france en particulier notamment pour
profiter du fait qu'on a une électricité
décarbonée il faut que les batteries
défectueuses bagnole électrique soit
s'est impliqué dans les pays qui ont
l'électricité la moins carboné possible
aujourd'hui à dans 30 ans et donc quand
nora qu'il faut les fabriquer en france
en suède en norvège
c'est là que ça sera le moins émetteurs
de co2 pour le cycle de vie complet de
la voiture ou du caméo d'autobus ou du
treuil électrique et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles ça sera un grand
service à rendre à l'ensemble de
l'humanité que de réindustrialiser la
france pas seulement pour donner du
boulot en français et là aussi il faut
interroger un peu rudement les
dirigeants politiques parce que
réindustrialiser la france
ça veut dire aussi se poser la question
des matières premières qu on utilise
je vous rappelle que à gauche tout le
monde a dit oui vous avez la sauver la
sidérurgie française etc
mais personne n'a répondu à la question
d'où vient le minerai de fer d'où vient
sa robe on a besoin pour voir de l'acier
qui font le sel on me dit tu verras bien
sûr qu'il faut poser la question et les
pauvres à la question devient
et donc si vous voulez avoir et je vais
arrêter là
monopoliser la parole mais si vous
voulez avoir une vraie planification
écologique de la transition énergétique
et d'une politique qui permettra de
diminuer drastiquement les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre de nos pays il faut
répondre à toutes ces questions
et quand on n'est pas capable de
produire des matières premières sur le
sol d'ascq nationale dont on a besoin
pour son économie pour répondre aux
questions suivantes tour les apports et
comme on ne les paye et toutes les
régions politique qui n'est pas capable
de répondre à cette question là il n'est
pas capable de gouverner la france en
fonction des promesses qu'il a fait et
c'est entre autres pour ça qu'on peut
avoir des échecs dramatique de
gouvernants gauche qui termine ensuite
par le retour de la droite au pouvoir
n'est pas présentée ci mais ce que je
réalise ce scientifique et qui anime un
blog sciences au carré vous avez
peut-être consulté alors peut-être que
denis durand qui l'économie ce que tu es
une réaction de mes rude
une remarque à propos d'une profondeur
de silvestro 21h beaucoup de propos
d'aurélie trouvé le partage quasiment
intégralement ce que vient de dire s'il
veut être sur la question des ismes je
voudrais aussi d'accord que mais des
ismes par tous les c'est pas très élevé
petit éviter adéquat du mythe de la vie
cela étant ça rappelle quelque chose
c'est que des questions écologiques sont
partis d'un système c'est à dire ce que
marx a montré aussi quand il dit que le
capitalisme et puis de choses
l'être humain et la nature c'est que
c'est un système d'ailleurs opposé
préservation de l'environnement et les
questions sociales comme le montant
dangereusement
coup sur coup à droite mais aussi et
parfois ailleurs c'est se tromper c'est
le rapport que derrière il ya un système
j'ai rédigé en commun de l'humanité qui
sont le climat qui sont là la
biodiversité etc
ce sont des biens communs de l'humanité
7 milliards d'êtres humains concernés et
les parcs qui sont des décisions par
quelques milliers de traders dans les
salles de marché et de dirigeants de
multinationales
c'est ça le scandale de notre société et
ça tapait le capitalisme le capitaine
sinon série et mondialisé dans lequel
nous vivons et c'est ça que nous voulons
qu'on a nous voulons nous attaquer au
capital et c'est pour ça que parti
communiste français lance une campagne
contre le coût du capital et de ce point
de vue là drake là aussi marqué mon
accord très vite avec la mise au point
de retrouver sur cette question du pid
de la croissance ce que nous voulons
faire décroître
c'est le coût du capital et les dépenses
qui étaient très d'environnement si les
terres spillane le capitaine matériels
et financiers mais ne voulant faire
croître les dépenses qui contribuent au
développement des êtres humains les
services publics c'est vital pour
l'environnement sas est donc
parfaitement d'accord pour consulter la
sur la taxe sur les transactions
financières la voix je suis assez vieux
pour avoir déjà été membre du parti
communiste en 1995 et à l'époque nous
acheter quatre ans la fondation date à
nu au parti communiste mission pour une
taxe sur les transactions financières
mais quand j'entends aurait voulu dire
c'est formidable attaque ce chroniques
sont financées à ça va rapporter était
partout des médias ça m'interpelle
parce que si la taxe les transactions
financières
apprendre beaucoup ça veut dire qu'il ya
beaucoup de transactions financières ça
veut dire que les marchés financiers
tout en a plein est ce que c'est une
bonne nouvelle
je pense que c'est je pense que tu seras
d'accord mais notre objectif c'est
précisément que le premier set at elle
diminue et que les ressources n'est
d'ailleurs est halal a dit la banque
centrale européenne un gt 2 700 millions
sont les marchés financiers pourquoi
faire pour préparer prochain sera le
prochain train et l'aract et en 2018
et là est ce qu'elle soit actuellement
bras tellement on a tellement vers la
catastrophe
qu'est ce qu'ils font jeudi dernier il
décide de recommencer et oracle et un
milliard par mois
et ça c'est insupportable et comme tu
l'as dit le mur
c'est de dire des c'est armand il doit
servir à développer des dépenses pour
les êtres humains
j'ai services publics en europe et sarah
la même
ça va lui donner les moyens de combattre
la menace climatique et de réussir cette
révolution ait connu merci denis
je veux quand même un simon docteur
c'est que la question écologie s'est
énormément une question et que lui aussi
une question de démocratie de pouvoir et
ne pas limiter la démocratie juste un
jeu de caisse concert à l'échelle
individuelle et faudrait pouvoir décider
de comment on produit ou et qu'est-ce
qu'on finance qu'est-ce qu'on est là il
ya un très petit suite de démocratie
lorsque fait réagir nous intervenons
jean-marc vous voulez réagir à ce qui
c'est ce qui était tout de suite
l'argument est ce que je fais beaucoup
de questions sur la question de la
récession et la sobriété
j'insiste la sobriété serré c'est si on
si on produit moins en moins de pib
alors on me dit toujours mais on va
remplacer le pays des matériels part du
pib immatériel
j'aurais dû sortir une bonne intrigue à
l'école admettons que demain matin nous
produisions une voiture par an encore
notre l'industrie automobile tomba
qu'une voiture par an
les gens qui aujourd'hui sont du crédit
automobile apporte prince et services
table les gens qui assurent les
nouvelles voitures à la porte
enfin ces gens là les gens qui
apprennent à conduire à la porte
en ces gens là les gens qui réclament
tous ces gens là sont hors service
donc ce que je suis en train de vous
expliquer l'art c'est que d'imaginer
qu'on va garder des services sans les
flux industriels sous jacent c'est une
vue de l'esprit
ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas ça c'est
un truc d'économistes qui pensent que
les parts de kpe ouverts sont
indépendantes les unes des autres et
dans la pallice n'existe pas donc
j'insiste vraiment si les parieurs ce
qui est matériel et il a pris son
environnement c'est bien la production
physique les mètres carrés les tables et
chaises etc et tous les gens que je
connais ils sont d'accord pour on
rajoute de l'éducation et des musées à
partir du moment où ils ont 200 habiter
c'est à dire des mètres carrés de quoi
se déplacer c'est à dire des bagnoles
des bus de quoi manger c'est à dire de
la production physique agricole de quoi
se vêtir c'est à dire la production
physique
aweys est d'accord pour qu'on en plus on
rajoute des jeux vidéo soit dit en
passant pas toujours présent pour la
santé mentale mais ils sont pas d'accord
pour ce fils et de bouffer et se priver
david est quelque part et c'est avec
juste en face des services éducatifs de
jeu ça n'existe pas ça donc l'idée
encore une fois qu'on va pouvoir
totalement découpler l'économie qu'on va
supprimer la physique et ne garder que
les services ça n'existe pas deuxième
point je voudrais mentionner l'armée
américaine est un service public a tort
c'est tout à fait un service public
l'armée américaine est conservée elle
seule autant de casseroles que la france
donc l'idée que les services publics ça
a pas de crise sur l'environnement c'est
pas vrai c'est pas parce que ces
services publics j'adore les services
publics mais c'est pas le sujet c'est
pas parce que ces services que dès que
ça n'a pas de délai sûrement donc je me
suis tout à fait d'accord mais ce qui a
été dit à leurs fins ils restent ils
font l'essai des slogans aux vestiaires
tant qu'on n'a pas regardé la réalité
concrète des problèmes et on les invite
dans la discussion ensuite
[Applaudissements]
oui je voulais vous m'aidiez à silvestre
qui la hisse en première instance il a
raison sur les ismes sens que ce qu'il
ne dit pas c'est qu'il ya quelque chose
qui ne se présentent pas comme à nice
mme may qui est présent dans tous les
débats c'est l'écologie
moi je dis l'écologie cette expérience
passionnante et qu'est la science du 21e
siècle
mais c'est aussi un mouvement politique
pour moi c'est à risque et c'est un
isthme qui est totalement seul eu que
dans le capitalisme
quelques jours après avoir annoncé la
fermeture de 300 magasins et 3000
licenciements
un dirigeant du groupe carrefour est
allé dans une conférence à milan tony un
discours sur le bonheur des runes photos
de pierre tapie et tenait un discours
sur le thème chacun doit faire un effort
vous connaissez l'histoire des bons
gestes
chacun doit faire un effort et donc moi
je dis on arrête et fille de mme heather
de mettre en cause le discours dominant
de l'écologie politique
car le fond du sujet de la sobriété
c'est que le capitalisme peut très bien
vivre avec la sobriété pour les pauvres
la sobriété pour la majorité du peuple
pendant que les riches continuent à se
déplacer en hélicoptère
authier prier et d'autres gains de
charisme très bon vivre il suffit
d'écouter mettront d'ailleurs pour le
comprendre il suffit pour les grandes
multinationales
et investissent le groupe total le
premier au delà trois ans d'ailleurs
avec des stratégies à 10 15 ans
réinvestissent nord c'est ce qu'il va
appeler l'environnement est donc le vrai
sujet de la sobriété c'est de dire
'est-ce qu'on répond aux besoins sociaux
et humains est on passé pour voir le
point de vue des communistes est on part
du constituent des besoins des gens le
final une égaux at il voulu une chose
pour que ça fonctionne il faut vous
déplacer deux fois moins c'est à dire
qu'à la fête l'humour aux deux fois
moins de monde c'est ça ce que nous tous
nous serrer carotte pour équilibrer avec
la sortie du nucléaire
moi je pense que c'est une impasse je
pense que les familles comoriennes de ma
ville qui tous les deux ans prennent
l'avion pour aller voir leur famille aux
comores ont le droit d'aller aux comores
elles ont le droit de prendre l'avion
pour aller aux comores
si on ne parle pas des besoins sociaux
on ne peut pas construire de réponse et
c'est pour ça que je dis oui ils ont
fait un choix dans les ismes il faut se
rendre compte que l'urgence fina tic
c'est de poser la question du
capitalisme de la domination de l'état
par les intérêts privés
tant qu'on est dans cette société quoi
qu'on fasse tout même il ne se passera
rien au global et donc il faut mettre en
pause il est toutefois la question c'est
quoi une société et je concluais dessus
mais moi je suis convaincu qu'il faut
lui donner un nom et que contrairement à
ce qui a été du tout à l'heure sur
l'histoire du socialisme au 20e siècle
le socialisme est plein d'expérience sur
l'environnement on ne connais pas du
tout on pourrait parler par exemple de
l'agroforesterie y ont développé un mur
et c est dans les années 30
moi je dis oui il faut une autre société
que le capitalisme est il faut lui
donner son dont le socialisme
[Applaudissements]
romain tu me donner la parole je
voudrais quitter sur un beau d'abord on
parle du scénario négawatt mais pas
encore des énergies renouvelables on
parle d'énergie qui sont renouvelables
appartement ou considère fais utilise
des matériaux qui sont renouvelables
c'est pas le cas on se disait l'indium
de l'indium d'ici 2030 on va peut-être
plus bombardés et iulian du néodyme
aujourd'hui de lénine son compte
pourquoi chinois yang sais pas combien
on peut rien non plus donc on peut
discuter du scénario négawatt
mais aujourd'hui avec du charbon donc
qu'est ce que c'est vraiment quelque
chose de durable
on peut comparer avec l'ucl est allé se
monte ici c'est une meilleure
alternative ou une moins bonne
alternative
personnellement ma réponse est plutôt
que c'est une meilleure alternative mais
en fait la réponse c'est surtout qu'elle
est le prouver une mauvaise ou est ce
que on veut continuer donc notre chaque
fusion énergétique
un système qui chaque jour ce jeudi puis
en bosnie la planète oui ce qu on veut
essayer d'être même d'accélérer les
choses monde ce système pour permettre
les berges de seine
je me crois être déçus car oui moi je
pense qu'il n'avait pas reçu les besoins
de chacun se considèrent comme de croix
avant d'aborder trois on a des limites
physiques
on a des obligations le droit d'une amie
coloré la première vision deux fois par
an je veux bien entendre
trop comparer avec 2 aujourd'hui tient
en profite énormément et qui veut le pen
dix fois plus si vous faites maison
passive mag espère le premier des trois
c'est injuste l'obligation d'avoir un
mode de vie qui est soutenable pour tout
le monde et donc de revendre dedans
[Applaudissements]
question est ce qu'on veut c'est
vraiment un système l'histoire si ce
retrait laisse t il focalise sur la
question pour ou contre le nucléaire
douzy l'année suivante ils ont besoin
comme s'ils savent qu'ils soient
suffisamment centralisée organisés et
ont même pas rien nouveaux adhérents au
bien-être à la santé et la sécurité de
ses citoyens
est-ce que ça c'est réaliste compte tenu
des pressions majeur qui pensent qu'on
va devoir subir en gros probablement des
trois prochaines années à venir ne
serait ce qu'en termes de nourriture et
aussi en termes d'immigration la
supposée mavs ne serait-ce que la
désertification par celles plus elle est
un don qui suit ces scandales est-ce que
c'est réaliste
et est ce que ces soudaines parce que
comme on l'a dit on a perdu un bon
[Applaudissements]
d'abord merci mon conseiller m'a dit le
traité vieux tout à mon accord par
ailleurs
ça va ou sur la question des besoins les
déplacements divisé par deux d'abord je
prends tiff les pleurs sa demande par
exemple effectivement de relocaliser les
services publics pour des vrai service
public aux qualités de proximité alors
ça concerne avant tout les éleveurs mais
ça concerne aussi l'état et les moyens
qui donne aux collectivités locales pour
des services publics de proximité et la
manière aussi dans les services publics
nationaux ont des dessertes d'être aussi
des lignes secondaires des bureaux de
poste à mouzon d'un dans un grand nombre
de villes de villages etc pour qu'ils
aient des urgences book et et des unités
d'urgence des unités ou plusieurs buts à
lierre qui est un maillage du territoire
beaucoup plus dense qui a toute une
politique à mener pour relocaliser faire
en sorte que les gens ne se déplacent
pas pour pour le pour des problèmes de
santé à à toulouse une dizaine de
kilomètres ça donne aussi un rêve est de
faire mumuse aux questionnements de
l'aménagement urbain
je vous donne un exemple un mois il se
trouve que je suis parti ce qui vont se
retrouver à saclay alors c'est à dire
toutes les écoles qui sont dans paris on
se retrouve à s'atteler au plateau de
saclay on est en moyenne on va se
retrouver à 1h30 de notre lieu de
travail de résidence
est ce que vous imaginez la transition
écologique avec un métro qui n'arrivent
pas jusqu'à sa très loin de là il va y
avoir des dizaines et dizaines des
centaines de voitures en plus pour aller
à saclay parce qu'on ne se retrouve là
plein de tôle et des gens qui avaient
jeunes saison voilà ce que c'est
aujourd'hui la vraie politique réelle et
les conséquences et donc du coup il ya
beaucoup déjà de choses à faire pour
éviter ces déplacements les réduire
drastiquement en france effectivement
aussi à la question la redéfinition des
besoins et nos besoins ils sont
construits aussi car le consumérisme
c'est pas une vue de l'esprit c'est à
dire que l'on nous met aussi
devant les yeux un modèle qui celui que
tu entends voyage quatre fois par an en
avion c'est vachement bien fait partie
des riches et de là au coeur classe
voilà c'est ça aussi qu'il faudrait
interroger nos besoins et villes sont
construits et peut-être qu'il faut
redéfinir par des débats démocratiques
ses besoins et peut-être que oui
qu'entre par ailleurs la question du
voyage et aux comores à s'excuser - se
pose pas pour les classes précaire est
ce parce qu'elle se pose pour certaines
classes sociales et oui il va falloir à
mon avis redéfinir ses nos zones comme
ça vient d'être deuxièmement sur la main
sur les questions dennis mme lamarche
tout ça très important en fait parce que
je pense qu'il faut re politiser cette
édition fort politiser les questions et
l'écologie elle est politique
et oui mars et moi moi je suis pour les
cours socialisme et 9,6 et c'est un seul
et même système le capitalisme qui
exploite le travail et le vivant et du
monde dumont ainsi créé twitter qu'il en
est mais on le reprend rené dubois en
disant exactement la même chose
et oui c'est la logique profondément
capitaliste tel cas se passe aujourd'hui
financière néolibérale qui est en jeu et
donc c'est une question profondément
politique est un jeu qu'il savait
l'écologie ce n'est pas qu'une question
de mesures à prendre
c'est une question d'ordre définition du
système et c'est pour ça que je pense
que oui elle est primordiale elle vient
pas à la fin en fait cette question-là
10 parce que c'est un système à remettre
en cause et je suis j'ai récemment sur
la question m des luttes lors du
nucléaire d'abord pas vous êtes la santé
retient grand débat à gauche arnaud
petit et que est que ce débat est non
seulement sur les risques
environnementaux mais sur la question du
coût d'un petit personnage une ânerie
pour évacuer le débat qui traverse toute
la gauche évidemment si un grand débat
là dessus
notamment sur la question du coût alors
on peut voir des lézatois et je trouve
qu'ils sont fait qu'on nous attaquons
mais les accords
si le débat n'est pas tranché dans
l'attaqué d'accord il est étranger dans
un tas de dorota de se faire à gauche
mais demeurant sont en disant vous vous
êtes des havres non il faut être
raisonnable et surtout respectueux les
uns raison de nos arguments voilà vous
avez les arguments j'en ai yang au nord
à gauche qui sont différents et vous
tournez le débat de manière je dirais un
peu posé à l'aspect eux pour ton aide
jusqu'au bout sur cette question
notamment du nucléaire qui est centrale
et finesse une question qui est celle
des luttes puisque 21 septembre vous
avez parlé de la caisse de la question
de la paix évidemment le vent la
versenne cette offre vous avez qu'il
émerge pour les jeunes pour le climat
mais surtout il quelque chose de très
important le samedi c'est le fait qu'on
veuille une convergence entre les
syndicats de salariés mais mouvement
pour le climat des mouvements gilet
jaune tout un tas de mouvements pour
faire converger ces questions de justice
sociale fiscales et environnementales
justement parce qu'on s'attaque à le
même système justement parce que cette
question a les politiques dont je vous
accorde tous les médias nationaux
mobilisation
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve aussi qu'il ya une
question à gauche qui va falloir on peut
régler c'est notre rapport à l'
expertise scientifique c'est à dire on
fait un petit peu tous nos marchés
niveau de la science je disais pour le
giec tout à l'heure la partie du giec
qui dit qu'à l'échauffement climatique
et qu'il faut agir vite on sera tous
d'accord là dessus mais le giec eux qui
parlent de la nécessité dans les
scénarios mondiaux de développer dit
nucléaire eh bien là c'est parti du g20
coup on n'en veut pas et ça posera aussi
un problème ce que pour embaucher un
autre exemple c'est le stockage de
l'électricité quand on a envie que
aujourd'hui si on met tous les barrages
qui testait minutes à vous en france on
n'a que quelques heures de stockage de
consommation française et 7
et si on avait de quoi investir 300
milliards une somme extraordinaire en
batterie chimiques pour pouvoir avoir un
scénario de type négawatt 100%
renouvelable avec le problème des
intermittences eh bien on aurait de quoi
stocker l'électricité pour appelle un
jour de consommation française je vous
laisse imaginer les longues semaines
d'hiver où il ya plus de soleil et de
toute l'europe recouvert d'un
anticyclone et ça ce sont des résultats
scientifiques c'est pas un complot
mondial contre les énergies
renouvelables c'est qu'on a vraiment des
obstacles technologiques notamment sur
le stockage d'électricité qui invalide
des scénarios que ceux de négawatt qui
sont pas reconnus dans la communauté
scientifique et ils n'ont jamais mis
comment dire 13 ans dit devant des
scientifiques comme ça se fait qu'on a
et oui je sur deux choses vont en avoir
une avec l'autre la première c'est pour
rebondir sur le débat sur le nucléaire
en fait je veux juste faire une remarque
ainsi dans ce qui passe sur le nucléaire
qui est une phrase que vous connaissez
peut-être qu'ils aient les faits ne sont
pas des opinions
le fait que la terre fait un soin ondes
efface 13 8 kilomètres de diamètre
c'est pas une opinion c'est pas faire et
quand on a des débats pour l'avenir qui
tentent de nier les faits c'est à dire
de penser que les faits sont des
opinions en général les plans qu'on fait
pour l'avenir se viande marche pas donc
le nucléaire il est essentiel dans ce
débat là dans d'autres de séparer les
faits d opinion et il ya énormément de
gens qui confondent les deux dans ce
domaine et en particulier mais d'une
façon plus large
voilà un jour des jeux indique juste les
gens et je vous donnais juste un petit
truc là dessus qui dans cette salle a
entendu parler de lui une star en plus
la personne qui a questionné les indices
alors une star ça veut dire hewitt n
échappe donc c'est un organisme onusien
comme le giec united nations scientific
committee
donc ça fait de la science en tant que
ça résulte de la science visiblement
andy effects of atomic re édition donc
cette à l'organisme onusien qui fait
exactement comme le giec une population
de la littérature scientifique qui porte
sur les impacts connu des rayonnements
ionisants part à des activités sur les
angles qui a déjà lu un document dans
cet instant dans la salle
c'est 3,4 c'est à dire tous les autres
vous savez ce que vous savez par le goût
d'un téléphone arabe dont vous ne
connaissez guinée par un intermédiaire
ni la fiabilité de chaque transition
vers les documents vous verrez là vous
avez de l'information primaire bel effet
voilà c'est juste une petite incidence
que je faisais pour dire dans ce débat
là que vous allez tomber trop chess
parce qu'ils vont me trouver à peu près
l'opposé de ce qu'on raconte à presse
française
donc il ya quelque chose de très
important vraiment qui est séparée sur
la partie argent je voulais revenir là
dessus aussi pour dire que le
financement de la transition pour moi je
suis et malgré mon côté sale gamin tout
à fait d'accord avec monsieur qui ont
été dits c'est évident que le
libéralisme financier va dans le mauvais
sens leur camp jeu proposé de supprimer
la cotation en continu c'est encore plus
violent que l'on taxe les transactions
financières est-ce qu'il ya plus de
transactions financières de tous en
routine
je suis tout à fait d'accord pour faire
payer les riches plus que les autres
jeux problème avec ça je suis tout à
fait d'accord pour qu'on évite le libre
échange j'ai pas de problème avec ça
par contre je vous dis il ya des
conditions aux limites physiques on a un
grand pas à violer donc en et de france
qui produit 6% sa nourriture tout le
monde n'ira pas dans une amap c'est
physiquement impossible
physiquement un dossier donc ça veut
dire que la stratégie à long terme cfrt
consul de france
des millions de personnes en
ile-de-france est juste pas soutenable à
long terme
le plateau de saclay au navire j'habite
pas loin c'est une énorme connerie
je les dis l'assument très bien
l'organisation du triangle de gonesse
c'est une connerie
parfaitement d'accord avec ça cela étant
la chose sur laquelle je voudrais
insister c'est que une fois qu'on m'a
dit tout ça il ya quand même une large
partie de l'argent de la transition qui
va venir de nos poches parce que je vois
pas d'où ça peut venir ailleurs et alors
je vais prendre un exemple qui est la
rénovation du logement vous allez en
france 30 millions de logements
bonjour appel et tertiaire un vent
millions de logements ça fait 3
milliards de mètre carré pour rénover
sérieusement un mètre carré il faut
compter entre 500 et 1000 euros
donc on fait une toute petite règle de
trois d'accord ça fait un premier de 500
et 3000 milliards d'euros et bien même
si vous tombez l'évasion fiscale ce à
quoi je suis parfaitement d'accord que
ça suffit pas donc ça veut dire qu'il
faudra obliger les propriétaires à
rénover les logements donc je suis pas
responsable
très à l'aise avec l'idée que l'état
aide le premier ou le deuxième décide de
propriétaire pas de problème avec ça
tous les autres y perdent eux mêmes
aucun problème une paire ont eux mêmes
et ils iront moins en vacances aux
commandes si l'on est comme ça
sinon on s'en sortira jamais donc il
faut faire les calculs top d'andorre
anton pas d'argent il suffit pas juste
de dire faire payer les riches encore
une fois j'ai pas de problème avec ça
mais par contre il ya des tas
d'activités qui n'ont aucune utilité
sociale avec laquelle je suis tout très
à l'aise quand on fait que on le rendre
la vie beaucoup plus difficile par an
qu'il ya deux choses qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est si on propose de
supprimer la grande distribution on a un
sujet qu'est ce qu'on fait des salariés
de la grande distribution pour que ce
temps moi je suis toujours en plus ans
sauf qu'il faut s'occuper
qu'est-ce qu'on fait des salariés qui
bossent dedans donc en fait le seul
chantier temps tendent à ce genre de
truc c'est pas les actionnaires en
championnat je peux vous dire que dans
sa capitale et je suis copropriétaire
mon entreprise
y'a jamais été dit nulle part en contrat
social que quand vous êtes investisseurs
dans votre entreprise vous garantit
votre taux lyon moi j'ai pris le risque
de le perdre ça fait partie du deal
donc tous les actionnaires de carrefour
ont pris le risque de perdre à pognon
dans carrefour j'ai aucun problème avec
ça son que seul sujet carrefour c'est
les gens qui y voit ce genre concept
carrefour ont pris un risque
sinon on n'aura jamais dit que donc
faire maigrir la grande distribution je
tiens formellement par contre j insiste
sur un point
ça va faire monter les prix ta bouche
des gens insiste oxydatif donc le juste
pour dire donc encore une fois et c'est
bien parce qu'on va tous devoir passer à
la casserole
tous insistent sur le plan monétaire ou
sur le plan financier que c'est
important d'être à peu près d'accord sur
ce qu'on fait de l'argent
donc j'en reviens à la remarque a été
faite par steve est d'abord on commence
parfois par parler concrètement des
problèmes à s'entraider
ensuite on parle de la manière de les
résoudre qui semble la plus sympathique
pour la collectivité et ensuite on nous
donne un non problème avec ça et en ce
bureau mais c'est bien dans ce sens là
qu'il faut faire les choses parce que
j'insiste on va tous passer à la
casserole tous
[Musique]
je suis pas le temps de laisser la
parole à l'un ou consultés on conclura
oui alors je vais répondre très
brièvement sur les questions
énergétiques
oui sur les questions énergétiques
moi je suis sensible à scania je pense
qu'on a besoin dans notre société de
revaloriser les expertises scientifiques
la parole scientifique a été dévoyé par
mois et coûté je pense que ça donne du
sens même s'il faut pas forcément leur
donner dernier mot en tout cas sous les
informant et par exemple sur les
questions énergétiques
je pense qu'on peut dire objectivement
qui a aucune source d'énergie qui n'est
pas d'inconvénient environnementale dont
un moment où plus ou moins et je crois
que s'il ya un point qui peut nous
mettre d'accord c'est qui a besoin de
continuer à investir dans la recherche
française pour trouver les solutions
pour demain parce que la solution idéale
elle n'existe pas deuxième remarque
pourquoi ce que disait ainsi sylvestre
tout à l'heure et industrialiser la
france oui évidemment
je crois que on a parlé circulant avec
le secal la caution des circuits courts
oui il faut qu'on commence à devenir
produisant locale
notamment par rapport à tout ce que je
disais à tout élu d'introduction sur la
question des transports
je vais l'essayer à une certaine en
disant que je crois que c'est nécessaire
de continuer à utiliser des moments haut
risque parce que je pense qu'il faut
qu'on fasse voir des choix de société
qu'on donne un idéal de société pour
demain je disais qu'il fallait qu'on
invente ensemble qu'en tout cas il ya
besoin vidéo de rupture parce que le
modèle actuel il est il avait refusé il
est dépassé il ya besoin d'une
révolution c'est pas moi qui le dit
c'est nicolas hulot a fait des mauvais
choix politiques d'assumer ses actes en
rapport avec ses idées ça sera très bien
et puis on va être d'accord et en même
temps que je dis tout ça et en même
temps que je dis tout ça si je peux me
permettre l'expression et en même temps
je crois qu'il ya besoin sans enrôler
les genres dans des ismes de faire des
propositions très concrètes qu'ils
soient appropriable par tous ce que je
disais tout à l'heure à 37 milliards
d'euros dans la rénovation des armes
nucléaires il n'y a pas besoin d'être
communiste n'a pas besoin d'être
socialiste pas besoin d'être un as ta
qui attend d'être nulle part si on est
d'accord avec cette idée là est ce qu'on
est capable de se mobiliser ensemble
pour que on oblige le gouvernement à
prendre cette disposition où on
travaille
un moment qui soit capable de
l'appliquer et je vais terminer en
disant que moi je crois que je suis
responsable politique j'ai quand même un
peu plus de confiance sur le fait qu'il
ya un gouvernement de gauche serait une
politique plus favorable pour l'écologie
que le fait un gouvernement de droite
una cordistes ce qu'on veut un peu au
même et je pense que là on avait un
débat pluraliste on n'est pas tous
d'accord n'écoute pas tous de gauche ça
c'est pas le problème
je crois qu'on est capable de se mettre
d'accord sur beaucoup de choses dans les
petites questions accord sur lequel on
arrive à faire pas se mettre d'accord
dans le nucléaire mais pour beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres choses pour les on est
d'accord donc est ce qu'on est capable
de travailler à un programme unitaire
tout le climat pour la planète qui nous
rassemble qui nous veut élargir un
certain monsieur et qui donne
perspective politique à nos concitoyens
et je termine en disant on sera la
machine à 12 c sur
et encore une fois je pense que ça vient
rousset tout à l'heure dans son discours
la dent en jute d'honneur sur la grand
scène parlera beaucoup d'écologie et une
voix que ce débat sera terminé je pense
qu'on peut aller l'écouter ensemble
effectivement on a des débats mais il se
trouve que autour de moi les quatre
intervenants ont chacun contribué dans
une revue du parti communiste dont on a
rêvé des points de vue qui il ya
beaucoup de convergences ou signé avec
leur en respectant la pluralité dans une
revue du parti communiste donc on ya une
ouverture regagné de réflexion et
notamment le livre que j'ai eue là deux
mois de l'issue de schiste project que
tu diriges sur la dé carbonée l'économie
y a rien de choquant que j'ai lu j'étais
même très impressionné par le détail les
propositions il ya tout un travail
d'expertisé surtout libre que vous
pouvez retrouver au village du livre et
il yad'autres libre alain pagano qui a
écrit un livre en récemment sur sur
l'écologie donc effectivement on peut se
retrouver sur
chose aurélie qui a aussi beaucoup bossé
société strike on lit ici
donc voilà on écrit par le temps le
débat était organisé par la revue
progressiste donc je vous fais une
petite page de publicité si vous voulez
retrouver toutes ces thématiques
on a un trimestriel qui s'appelle donc
progressiste on a fait des dossiers
complets sur les énergies renouvelables
mais aussi chaud énergie me taire on a
fait des dossiers sur l'agriculture on a
fait des dossiers sur la biodiversité
etc et ceux qui écrivent dans cette
revue ne sont pas tous communistes il ya
jean marc jancovici qui à aurélie trouvé
ya qu il ya un tas de monde et on a
beaucoup de scientifiques de très haut
niveau qui ont déjà écrit dans cette
revue l'un et nous voilà on propose cet
espace de débats de propositions pour
construire un lacet un mot en cette
liste donc on réutilise un ministre
progressiste
vous pouvez découvrir tout ça il va y
avoir le débat
le discours de fabien roussel sur la
scène c'est à 15 heures que je vous
invite à y aller 15 15h15 ya déjà un
débat oui et 15h30 celle des mains de
mai vous pouvez poursuivre la discussion
peut être avec nos intervenants si si si
j'ai encore une petite disponibilité
seront très rapides merci à tous merci à
toutes et à tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]